let's talk about tunnel vision when it
comes to your job search my name is
Martin McGovern with Udacity and
recently I was chatting with a job
seeker who had a really hyper focused
view of the company that they wanted to
work at they sent me a message saying I
applied many times at Google but they
just don't respond back so I'm trying to
make my resume as good as possible
because I want to get in to Google now I
understand their desire and maybe one
day they will work at Google but the
truth of the matter is everyone wants to
work at Google so we're in a position
where we need to open up the world of
possibilities when it comes to their job
search we chat it back and forth and I
shared this message with them you
shouldn't get hyper focused on any
single company maybe you'll get into
Google someday but by focusing on only
one company right now you're missing out
on all the other opportunities that
might come your way also you never know
what job or contract you might pick up
in the meantime that is one step away
from Google if only you jumped at it
they agreed and expanded their search to
include both Microsoft and Amazon saying
slowlyslowly I will increase my search
to more companies but these companies
focus on quality which is what I really
like about them now they're on the right
track they not only know what it is
about these companies that they like but
they've expanded the number of companies
that they're looking at this is a great
start but I want to challenge them and
even you if you feel like you have
tunnel vision to go even further here
are four steps that you can take to make
sure that you are expanding your options
while still keeping your eye on the
prize step number one pick your favorite
company step number two look up all of
their competitors and put them down on
paper step number three look up every
company that that company partners with
and number four create a web of all
these companies and find your way in
your first gig might not be with your
dream company but you can get close by
expanding your focus
thank you for watching if you have any
other career questions that you'd like
us to make videos about please put them
in the comments and if you know anyone
who's searching for a job right now tag
them and let them know you're thinking
about them we look forward to bringing
you many more videos in the future and
wish you the best of luck in your job
search
[Music]